yeah so you've been doing a lot more
streams now I got to ask what made you
want to do the stream where you sat in a
white room doing [__] nothing dude I
want to I want to steal this idea so bad
is that the one where we raided you when
he specifically texted us not to raid
you yeah you were doing the after dark
and I was like all right I'm going to do
this I'm going to message Connor do
please do not raate me I didn't see the
message and I'm like okay I I'll message
Joey in case as well Joey also didn't
see message cuz we were live I think at
the time concept of the stream you want
to tell people what it was uh so pretty
much I went into a white room like I
took a friend's apartment room uh made
the floors white with like sheets
everything white like the camera would
be just the lens I'd cover everything up
and I would just stay there essentially
it be like a saaton but for every sub
I'd stay there for like a minute or 2
minutes longer damn and how long were
you in there for it wasn't that long it
like 13 hours you said you said have
started the [__] with you right oh yeah
absolutely it was horrible yeah I mean
you literally put yourself in a psych
psychiatric hosit solitary confinement
yeah solitary confin there's been a lot
of studies that say that like being in
that kind of environment like after even
like a few days can like really cause
some mental well that was that vsource
video right it's really really bad for
you that's where I got the idea from
actually like Michael did it I was like
hm well he did a you most of my streams
have been like well people have done
YouTube videos I want to I can do it
live on a stream instead like you and
Conor have the same mindset with I want
to do that too I want to have some way
the chat can [__] with me though I feel
like that like kind of messes up the
dynamic of a white room so I'm going
more for the normal type of
psychological torture kind of like the
like the zoo type of vibe right where
people just look in but you can't
interact I feel like I feel like that's
boring though cuz you can
leave okay okay we have to say for
twitch you can always leave it's not
torture you can leave anytime you want
so yeah do a lot of streams a lot of the
time mooder streams and then I'll see
which ones are like not [__] and then
I'll I'll just take the ideas you
treadmill stream that seemed pretty
[__] yeah but I thought that'd be easy
honestly what do you mean it was so bad
it was like 14 hours of pain for me yeah
I thought no I could do it I I looked at
that and I was like this is one of the
more achievable moodang ideas and was it
like as achievable as you hoped yeah but
it was miserable it was an awful idea so
I did this stream where uh the viewers
could control or you did it first so
what you did one where you walked
100,000 steps yeah I wanted to do
100,000 steps on stream without stopping
even once so I got a Trad Mill I had
like different activities planned and it
was also like a donut so people gave
money Joey graciously like fed pretty
much 100 dogs by himself yep and cuz it
was funny and that also gave me like
20,000 more steps you're welcome um and
and so you did that and I thought well
that's good but I don't want to do it as
crazy and in my head I was like that's a
cool idea but I feel like marathon is
such a good clickbait word because it's
such a strong association with like and
it's easy to understand right yeah yeah
100,000 steps is I mean it's it's it's
much better than a marathon if you terms
of distance but I was like a marathon I
think makes sense so I did that but I
was like What if I let the viewers
control the speed of the treadmill right
so I I I got one of my moderators um to
program a treadmill that we could use
with the chat interactivity it was
miserable it's horrible I realized how
bad it is that someone else controls
your speed like that was the single most
worst aspect of it that you couldn't get
a pace that sounds like it I wonder if
that's like actually worse than at the
same pace for double the distance I
think I would I don't know it's hard to
say up your Rhythm right yeah because
the moment I would get comfortable they
would change it yeah and it would it
they could there was no delay on the
inputs so they could they were changing
it every half second I thought about
going faster at points as well but uh
after doing a couple tests I figured out
that no it has to be exactly the same
amount the entire way through otherwise
it's like too much like muscle effort
yeah you need your legs to get like so
used to it and like like the like when
cuz when you startop walking at any
point your legs
like also it like [__] with your
balance as well right which is important
cuz like if if you're nice and balanced
on a treadmill then it's like less
energy everyone has like an optimal
stride yeah and like a stride that is
like least resistance for you and you'll
find it by [__] around on the
treadmill or like it's what you're
running on a treadmill as well and
you're like I could run faster but I
will be able to run way less in like the
next 30 minutes if I do this because I
it's just going to be more work for me
yeah for sure um that was miserable so
but good luck editing that that's an 8
hour video going up in a couple days is
it really is it fun it must have been
awful to edit uh it was decent cuz you
didn't do much yeah there was kind of
hard to do anything it was like you
complaining for 50% of the time that was
kind of it yeah that's just every Conor
video well that's a lot of it that's a
lot of it just Conor in general in fight
but hey it was only a one stream mud
messaged me one time was like Conor you
you got to stop doing these streams that
are like five streams into one video
yeah you talking about his fear and
hunger videos how's it editing that many
hours that one good well the videos
perform well I know the videos are going
to do well but he he does like all right
fear and hunger fear and hunger all
endings then it was like uh something
else that was like 20 hours and for like
a month straight you only filmed videos
that were 20 to 30 hours long and each
video takes like a month to edit and you
need two videos out a week it's like
please make a meme review so so then
make a
m so there I was like all right honey
yes honey I'll make I'll make a meme
review and every time you go like on a
trip I need to be like we don't have
enough videos please yeah I have then
I've had to yesterday I had to do a
stream I did two videos in one right
right um I'm fine with the backlog but
for some reason every time winter comes
you're like Mudan can we do four videos
a week I'm like can we so for so for
context uh mood and runs my streaming
Channel but we like we split the uh the
the ad Revenue that we get um and we
we're kind of like I guess we strateg on
how to make it like perform well and a
lot of the time it sucks but if you like
cut up videos like a lot of people would
rather just watch one hour of something
just have it go through it all then four
videos of 15 minutes for sure which
which is bad for the YouTube channel if
you're trying to upload two two a week
because it's like okay now how do we
keep this going cuz some some games you
know like they just they naturally run
their course at like 20 hours of
playtime but if you split up into two
videos the first video will get tons of
views and no one's going to watch the
second video cuz it's just how that's
just how it goes for some reason all old
YouTube used to be able to get away with
that but now used to upload 30 [__]
Parts I know and you watch all them yeah
and now I'll do like a 100 hour playr
I'll be like wa can we get into one
video
please um so yeah how you How do you
keep saying during those types of videos
where it's just like one thing cuz I
mean I I I have this same problem where
I send my editors like the 20th genin
video and they're like please gone
please I'm do something else I B of you
and I'm like all right I got you honkai
star baby oh my God we'll do it like
back to back you know like honai gen
honai up got to spread it out you got to
spread it out and then and then I'm like
all right fine I'll do a tear list video
it's it's okay it's okay I'll do an Igan
anime list review it's fine I I got to
ask has there ever been at a point where
you've been watching a trash taste
episode and something one of us has said
has made you like legitimately
angry
times I've noticed I've started to
notice in recent trash Chas episodes
whenever someone says something usually
Corner uh there's like a little like
window that pops up being like um
actually yeah this is very helpful to
have actually well it works sometimes
when you're kind of doubting yourself as
well but sometimes I don't notice it cuz
you're like well yeah that's true for
sure just you just say it out there I
don't even notice you're like yeah
that's a fact you know I know this I'm
like all right okay what okay what is
the most egregious thing that we said
was a fact that was wrong I know the
most annoying thing was uh why do they
put the white uh paint on airplanes oh
oh cuz there's no solid answer online
the [__] up thing was that you looked
on the Google like why is uh why is it
that and it said oh cuz black paint is
heavier and then somebody Googled some
other thing and it said dos it but the
thing was it was literally both of them
in the same article and at the end of
the article it just said this statement
is false and then the they just
said what the [__] is the point of that
article then Jesus no it's Google that
like picks that correct answer but it
like messes up well Google Google has
has this bad thing where if you feed it
the qu the answer you want like you ask
the question in a way it will find an
article that gives you the answer that
you kind of were looking for a lot of
the time uh which is kind of bad cuz a
lot of the time you're like yes I guess
I'll Trust the first thing that popped
up which is annoying and OB yeah so like
the Mudan fact checks that like are on
screen every so often we did not tell
him to put that
on I'll do myself that was a him thing
and we kind of just I didn't we need it
I didn't even notice it and people until
people started commenting about it like
oh thank God mood on is back I'm like oh
my God this is such a brilliant
idea pcks are very helpful with some of
things you said I was like what this I
can't do this
anymore so what's he talking about it's
also like some things need like a wall
of text for context my girlfriend is
also optometrist she she's uh studied
like how the eyes and stuff work and you
have a lot of hot takes about um you
know dark mode and how glasses work and
she just keeps editing and was like bro
what are they saying so [__] up and
then I'd hear like a 10-minute rant
about how all is wrong like all
right you do well wait isn't isn't it
actually that okay I'm going to give you
on right now so you can work with isn't
it that like light mode actually is
better for your eyes or something the
way the contrast works if you have a
stigmatism then it's like better cuz you
perceive like the contrast is better
yeah okay okay yeah well then there we
go check on the spot yeah sounds like a
skill issue so it's literally day Get
Better Eyes in yeah get good eyes I'm
I'm sorry I don't have 2020 Vision guys
all right call me out okay I'm I'm
trying okay I'm
trying I'm going to I'm going to get uh
surgery eventually C literally uh she
recently actually just got I uh did she
convert back to dark
mode I mean good question it's good
actually you know I don't think she ever
has ever she should try it okay here's
the thing she's now that I think about
it she's also a light mode user but
that's because it's just default in most
apps I just don't think she uh so she
just another fact that mud's going to
have to
check I think the most common surgery in
the world is like the uh the replacing
the lens of your eye um cataracts is it
oh but you know cuz you when you you
just age naturally it gets cloudier so
they just when you get older you just
get it changed at some point I think
that's the most common Sur I really hope
when this episode goes up the box is
just going to say no you f that be so
but I'm setting it up so good if I'm
right POG if I'm wrong okay you're an
idiot they're also like so good at doing
it now but you'll probably we'll all
probably have to get it when we're if we
make it to 80 yeah well M certainly will
with all his vitamins but I'm it's very
questionable I'll make no I I knew I did
the 23m me with the genetics me too me
too going to get [__] up oh [__]
really what what are the health things
they tella dude me too oh [__]
yeah [__] yeah
dementi I actually forgot about
that yeah they said uh Alzheimer's as
well they said I had a high chance and I
was [__] myself because they said oh
you have a high chance of Alzheimer I
like [__] okay that sounds bad and I
click on it and and their like high risk
category meant like 1% extra chance or
something I was like right I was like
bro are you kidding me I gamble with way
worse odds I'll take 1% I they also
check like one like sequence out of 50
possible ones so even if that's low the
other can be high so well yeah cuz mine
said like like like very low chance of
balding so that was a [__] lie so
that was a lie straight lie go watch the
video it's still on YouTube you can see
it wow we should uh I I should I should
do one and then we should reveal it on
trash days you know what's annoying did
you get this emails all the time cuz I I
did I did the ancestry and I did we
found a new we found a new cousin I
don't [__] care I don't want a new
cousin I don't want any cousins I get
that so often I have to mut it just my
life
like I was going to say I was like this
is how much like how gun describes all
his relationships family just like we
found three cousins I I don't want of
these [__] new cousins I don't know
I'm happy with the cousins I have it's
like every family meeting I have I'm
just like oh that's a new cousin like a
cousin cousin or like a
cousin and they like yes but you know if
I'm like three connections away not like
like it's so like sparse the connection
I'm like yeah why are you telling me I
don't care who does this interest yeah
I'm not going to go meet [__] Barry
Dinger in [__] you know North
Carolina Barry Dinger like North
Carolina's like fourth remov like I'm
not going to go [__] meet him but you
can travel all over the world you just
have a place to say that's a Mr Beast
video I contact all of my cousins for
Battle
Royale you're probably wondering why
I've all dragged you into the group chat
only one of us can continue the
bloodline we're going to decide right
now that's just an average Asian
household except we're fighting over
inheritance for my grandma
[Music]
true
true that is just a yeah Asians are like
yeah we do that every generation
actually that's why I'm really good to
my
grandma